what's going on guys this is rob and
sony is apparently making a spin-off
project about el muerto from spider-man
and i don't know why because this guy
literally appeared in two comics it's a
two-part series and friendly
neighborhood spider-man issues six and
seven from 2005 called masks and like
that's it after that he's never seen her
from again i think he's referenced in
like the civil war files as part of the
50 state initiative but like he has no
meaningful appearances so i have no idea
how in the world they're going to make a
spin-off project about this guy but
those of you guys who are familiar with
this friendly neighborhood spider-man
was basically a spin-off spider-man
title not really a spin-off just kind of
another spider-man title that spider-man
has always been so popular in marvel
comics that for like decades they've
been able to get away with running like
two or three different spider-man titles
at the same time and in fact i think
right now in marvel comics they only
have one they've got like the amazing
spider-man and then you have like
spider-man miles morales but for a long
time you had like web of spider-man and
amazing spider-man and spectacular
spider he had like all kinds of titles
uh so friendly neighborhood spider-man
was just the most recent iteration of
that title running up into uh really
going into 2005. and so the idea behind
this is is really just kind of treating
this like a regular story because that's
really all it is um essentially just
kind of picks up with el muerto
basically fighting peter parker
wrestling peter parker and we don't
exactly know how we got to this point
all we really know is that we just have
like jay jonah jameson cheering on
spider-man basically getting defeated by
el muerto now the funny thing about this
is normally you would expect spider-man
to be able to like overcome this guy
quite readily but there is a caveat to
el muerto which is the mask that he
wears and we'll talk about that here in
a little bit but basically it allows him
to go toe-to-toe with peter parker so
much so that this fight actually ends up
becoming a little bit tougher than peter
parker initially thought that it would
and despite all of his attempts right to
dodge bob and weave to like come at this
guy from different directions none of it
really seems to work and so what this
does is it actually jumps back to the
past for for really kind of a few panels
and it shows us that somewhere along the
line there was this guy whose father was
arrested and uh had basically you know
he had like killed a cop right so he was
busted for capital murder he was charged
in prison and executed and so because of
j john and jameson's editorials which
were seemingly as this guy interprets it
uh the reason why his father ended up
basically being killed because the
governor would have pardoned him had his
father been able to basically
demonstrate that he was a new law
abiding citizen that because of de jones
jameson's editorial columns that the
governor chose not to and basically this
guy's father was essentially killed and
so where initially this guy's gonna kill
jameson and then kill his son in front
of him you end up having el muerto who
just kind of jumps in now the funny
thing about this is that el morto is
he's inherently spanish right he's from
mexico and so his english isn't all that
great but so the the way he speaks is
kind of funny right he's like back away
the weapons are to be put down by you
[Laughter]
and he even goes so far here is is
basically saying like excuse my english
it's not very well so i will use a
universally understood language the
language of violence because as we've
talked about here on comics explained so
many times before violence is not always
the answer but it is a answer and it's
usually a very effective one and so
basically el muerto just like beats this
guy up
he literally just starts pummeling and
then once this guy's defeated of course
he basically ends up uh freeing jay
jonah jameson and his son now when the
question's asked by jameson how in the
world did you even know to come here in
the first place the response of el morto
is i've actually been watching you for a
while i've been trying to find the best
way to approach you and i figured you
being tied up and about to be killed
would probably be the best time to step
in and make my presence known and so
again you do kind of jump back to the
fight between peter and el morto the
reality is it's it's ironically enough
it's kind of filler right like this
segment with spider-man is largely
filler stuff right i mean the two of
them wrestling and kind of getting the
upper hand and so on and so forth now
one of the things that had gone on here
is that when jameson was being held he
believed his son and even like for the
first bit of the story he believed his
son was actually spider-man that it
wasn't peter parker and the reality is
that peter parker had talked jameson
into believing that his son was
spider-man even though like robbie
robertson is like your son and
spider-man have been seen together at
the same time how is it possible that
your son could be spider-man if he's
standing right next to him and so it's
one of those funny little things
[Laughter]
but nonetheless like because of the fact
that james said it previously believed
spider-man could do no wrong because he
will leave the sun with spider-man as
soon as that revelation turned out to be
untrue it was back to business as usual
right he was back to jameson just being
a dick and always having it out for
peter and trying to take him out now at
that point you switch over to the origin
of el muerto which is really really
interesting to be honest so the whole
idea behind this is there's this guy
named estrada i think it's how you
pronounce it or straight up i'm not 100
sure how you pronounce this in spanish
but basically it's the father of el
morto and what it is is that the role of
el morto is really more of a title than
anything else that el morto is by all
standards of measurement what you or i
might call a luchador now i'm not super
familiar with spanish wrestling i know
that like there's a lot of heritage when
it comes to luchadores and there's a lot
of tradition that's there so it's not
necessarily something that you scoff
your nose at right i mean there's a lot
going on there in terms of history and
significance and that kind of stuff but
essentially the role of el muerto had
been passed down to el morto's father
from his father and from his father
going back to somewhere along the line
and so in order to basically take on
that mantle one el muerto had been
trained by his father since the day he
was born since he was a little kid and
two he has to wrestle this unnamed guy
basically do battle with him in order to
demonstrate that he's worthy of the
mantle if he fails he will be killed and
that's exactly what happens that in this
small man el morto basically backs off
he's like no no i don't want to have
anything to do with this like i don't
want to be part of this whole thing that
you have going on dad like it's nothing
that i want to be a part of but the fact
that he's violated the tradition both by
basically demonstrating cowardice and
backing away from a fight and then by by
that very nature losing the response of
this mysterious guy is then it's done
right like juan carlos basically his
life is forfeit because of the fact that
he backed away from this he dishonored
the tradition and he obviously is not
living up to the mantle of el morto his
life is over with his father actually
ends up jumping in to save the life of
his son and then his father's head is
ripped off we don't see it on on panel i
mean it is a spider-man comic right i
mean marvel's not really going to show
us super gruesome stuff like that but
they will show us stories where mary
jane watson dies because of peter
parker's irradiated fluids we'll leave
it there
that story did happen and i don't know
if it's in continuity but because of the
fact that el morto's father you know
juan carlos father demonstrated bravery
here juan carlos himself is given 10
years by this mysterious guy this guy's
basically basically what he tells him is
you have 10 years to find your courage
if that's even possible you have 10
years to train yourself to become more
capable and at the end of that 10 years
i will come for you and so in effect
because of the fact that el morto would
save the life of joanna jameson what he
wanted to do was basically challenge
spider-man because in doing so he would
be able to basically maintain his honor
right if he's able to defeat someone out
there in the world who is highly capable
and is also masked and then unmasked
them it would basically prove himself
being worthy in the eyes of this
mysterious guy hence the reason why this
whole match is set up now the reality
here is it is so much of a somewhat of a
charity thing they're not really
fighting to kill right i mean it's not
like this guy's gonna kill peter parker
in the ring it's simply just whoever it
is that loses basically gets unmasked
now peter parker does not initially know
this and that's one thing to specify
here that this guy basically at one
point in the match he says mascara
contra mascara which i'm not i'm sure
that i think that's how you find my
spanish is awful i mean it's it's really
terrible i apologize for you all out
there who are of spanish descent or who
speak the spanish language and i'm just
trouncing all over how things are
supposed to be pronounced
i apologize spanish is not a language
that i'm i'm overly familiar with but
basically in saying that is whoever wins
this match gets unmasked peter parker
not realizing what's going on just kind
of blows off the statement but as the
two of them begin to continue on this is
when almerto basically tells him because
i'm defeating you now like when i win i
will unmask you peter parker's like what
are you talking about he's like you
agreed to it right you literally agree
to that stance like you know whoever it
is that wins basically gets to unmask
the other person now in the midst of
this and because peter parker has the
iron spider suit and because this is
still a point in his history when he's
not overly familiar with it in this
battle with el morto you end up having
this kind of poison blade that comes out
from the the suit itself which isn't
enough to kill el morto but it's enough
to knock him unconscious and so because
of the fact that it appears that he's
been defeated the mysterious man
watching all this unfold basically says
you failed right your life is forfeit
and so at that point you switch over to
a hospital of course j jonah jameson
always having it out for peter he's like
obviously peter did this on purpose
right obviously peter you know
spider-man cheated because spider-man's
a terrible person and uh he rushed him
here to the hospital probably to assuage
his guilty conscience and then he's like
give me pictures of spider-man you know
like that kind of a thing right the
guy's just sort of being a dick but
ultimately what ends up happening here
is that as el morto begins to come too
of course he's met by jameson and he's
met by robbie robertson and they're like
look man you know you were basically
knocked unconscious temporarily
paralyzed because of a poison that was
injected in you by spider-man you know
that kind of a thing but like rest
assured everything's fine you're in this
hospital there's no safer place to be
only for this mysterious man to appear
out of nowhere and what we end up
finding out when jameson asks who this
guy is he's literally like i am el
dorado right el dorado is this guy's
name someone please explain to me how
sony's gonna be able to make a spin-off
film about this i can tell you right now
if sony makes a movie about this it's
gonna be bad it's gonna be a terrible
film just
bad bad like sony for the love of god
just let me plan things out for you let
me save you from yourself please please
let me do that but nonetheless
[Laughter]
right the way this goes down is that you
initially have jameson who just starts
talking trash to this guy obviously
because as much as jameson is a jerk one
thing you gotta credit him for is he
almost never backs down even when it's
in his best interest to do so he's just
like literally talking trash to this guy
but in the end like el dorado just like
brandishes these two swords right these
cutlasses and it's like time to get down
to business right so literally take out
el morto now the thing about this is of
course peter parker his spider sense he
senses something going on he ends up
tracing it to it's to his genesis point
where it's happening and he arrives here
on scene and ultimately like a fight
breaks out between him and el dorado to
the point where peter is actually able
to overcome this guy not necessarily in
like a straight-up fight it's really
more bobbing and weaving and just kind
of dodging attacks and different things
like that but for the most part peter's
kind of outclassed here now here's one
of the things to know about this this is
before peter parker was trained by shang
chi right that happened during hickman
during jonathan hickman's avengers new
avengers i need to go read that story
again but like this is before peter
parker learned how to learn his own
martial arts style and so up until this
point peter parker's fighting style was
really more street fighting if anything
right it was kind of his own style a
blend of different styles that he'd
learned over time and so this guy being
able to gain the upper hand is really
more of the fact that he's just that
prodigious of a fighter now it's not
like he's facing off against taskmaster
or anything like that but el dorado is
pretty capable and so all peter really
does here at least all he can do when he
tries to web him up right his webs are
just chopped pieces there's nothing he
can do and peter parker basically just
bails off and and literally buys himself
some time now what he ends up doing of
course is traveling to the laboratory
but one of the things that this guy
eldorado says is that his ability to
track people is highly prodigious right
he's very very capable that he doesn't
really have a spider sense like peter
does but he does have kind of like a
sixth sense as it's illustrated or the
ability to track people to particular
locations and so literally once he shows
up here on the scene and he realizes
that spider-man is in this room it's
literally spider-man just kind of
putting together a kind of cocktail and
as eldorado's hunting for spider-man and
then like the moment he's about to catch
him then el morto shows up out of
nowhere and then kind of a fight breaks
out between the two even if only
momentarily now for el morto this is a
pretty big deal right the ability to
basically overcome eldorado to show that
he is if not the more prodigious fighter
certainly comparable to eldorado in the
sense they're not necessarily equal but
he's still able to hold his own to a
degree not quite but to a degree but in
fact he actually slips on some glass and
then fall and bust his ass but like
that's basically it right so at that
point peter parker of course ends up
throwing this this you know these this
chemical at el dorado not gonna lie man
i feel like it'd be hilarious if it were
just like some kind of fear toxin or
something like that where this guy just
starts hallucinating these horrible
things and just runs off screaming i
feel like it that would have been
hilarious
i don't know why i've got a twist i
gotta you guys know man i've got i've
got a kind of messed up sense of humor
but nonetheless right uh this of course
basically buys them like a just a quick
moment of time but in effect peter saves
the life of el morto here right he
literally just pummels el dorado sends
him flying out of the room and then of
course having been defeated el dorado
takes off and that's it right that's the
last time that you see el muerto like as
far as i'm aware we've never seen or
heard from him since like that's it it's
him just kind of being like thanks peter
and like that's all there is to it right
and so uh you know my my question here i
don't know how you make a spin-off
project about this guy because it's not
like he's done anything important he
wrestled peter parker in order to unmask
him to prove his worth to some guy and
then ultimately peter parker defeated
that guy roll credits i mean is that
really is that what we're talking about
here i have no idea how they're gonna
make it work but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
let me know in the comments if you think
there's any possible way to make a
compelling spin-off series about this
guy and i will catch you all later
peace